From the biggest stadiums To the coziest holes in the wall From house parties to porch hangs to pride celebrations From your favorite fuzz shop to your local Indians vibe From noodle bars to sports bars to salsa bars There's a Molson with your name on it Canadian ultra XL
从最大的体育场 到最温馨的街角小店 从家庭派对到门廊聚会，再到骄傲节庆 从你最爱的绒线店到当地的印第安人风情 从面条吧、运动吧到萨莎舞吧 都有属于你的莫尔森加拿大超大号啤酒
Molson Everyone in Must be legal drinking age On the 29th of January 1999 best friends Laura Bible and Ashley Freeman had a sleepover at Ashley's house to celebrate her 16th birthday Ashley's parents Danny and Kathy Freeman were also at the house Which was actually trailer on a rural property in Welsh located in Craig County, Oklahoma, USA It was a remote area It was a pretty quiet uneventful night of eating cake and watching TV. Nothing seemed out of the ordinary
莫尔森 每个人都必须年满法定饮酒年龄 1999年1月29日，好朋友劳拉·拜布尔和阿什莉·弗里曼在阿什莉家过夜，庆祝她16岁生日。阿什莉的父母丹尼和凯茜·弗里曼也在家中，其实那是一辆位于美国俄克拉荷马州克雷格县威尔士乡村地区的拖车。那是一个偏远的地区。那是一个相当安静、平淡无奇的夜晚，大家吃着蛋糕看着电视。一切看起来都稀松平常
But about 6 a.m. The next morning a neighbor reported that the Freeman house is on fire Emergency services rushed to the scene and found the body of Kathy Freeman But where were Danny Laura and Ashley You Laura Bible and Ashley Freeman grew up in Veneta a town in Craig County, Oklahoma The population at the time was about six and a half thousand people Laura's born on the 18th of April 1983 Ashley was born later that year on the 29th of December 1983 Laura and Ashley first met each other in kindergarten
但在第二天早上6点左右，一名邻居报告说弗里曼家的房子着火了。紧急服务人员赶到现场，发现了凯茜·弗里曼的尸体。但丹尼、劳拉和阿什莉在哪里呢？你，劳拉·拜布尔和阿什莉·弗里曼在俄克拉荷马州克雷格县的小镇维内塔长大。当时的archiviato人口约为六千五百人。劳拉出生于1983年4月18日。阿什莉出生于同年稍后的1983年12月29日。劳拉和阿什莉在幼儿园第一次见面
They formed an instant bond and were basically inseparable ever since they only got closer as time went on and were the best of friends About as close as friends could get Loren Bible Laura's mother says that Laura and Ashley would call each other at least once a week What one was thinking the other was thinking when one of them started a sentence the other one would be able to finish it They attended the same schools and spent every waking minute together throughout their early school years But then in 1995 Ashley's parents decided to make a move to Welsh still in Craig County, Oklahoma about 32 kilometers away or 20 miles Well, it was a rural area with a population of about 600 at the time The Freedman's moved into a trailer on a rural property that they owned which was about 40 acres in size
她们一见如故，从此几乎形影不离，随着时间的推移关系越来越好，成了最好的朋友。堪称最亲密的朋友。劳拉的母亲洛伦·拜布尔说，劳拉和阿什莉每周至少通一次电话。一个心里想什么，另一个也心知肚明；一个人刚起头，另一个人就能接上话。她们上同一所学校，在早年求学期间，每一个醒着的分钟都黏在一起。但到了1995年，阿什莉的父母决定搬家，搬到依然在俄克拉荷马州克雷格县内的威尔士，距离大约32公里或20英里。嗯，那是一个乡村地区，当时人口约有600人。弗里曼一家搬进了一辆位于他们名下乡村地产上的拖车里，占地约40英里。
It was a pretty isolated remote quiet spot It was a testing time for the girls friendship, but they got through it They remained best of friends and still managed to see each other quite regularly. They called each other on the phone almost daily Laura and Ashley were your typical teenage girls. They loved hair makeup shopping clothes the usual stuff Both were also very good students and they were in the top 10% of their classes Laura was a cheerleader and had a passion and love for animals. Ashley was more of an athletic type that she was in the basketball team She loved hunting as well. She shot her first year around the age of 12 Ashley also had a job at a local convenience store and she hoped to save enough money by the time she turned 16 to buy a car
那是一个相当偏远、隐蔽且安静的地方。这对女孩的友谊来说是一场考验，但她们挺过来了。她们依然是最好的朋友，并且仍然设法定期见面。她们几乎每天都打电话。劳拉和阿什莉是典型的十几岁女孩。她们喜欢发型、化妆、逛街买衣服，也就是那些寻常事物。两人也都是非常优秀的学生，成绩名列班级前10%。劳拉是一名啦啦队员，对动物充满热情和爱心。阿什莉则更具运动型，她是篮球队成员。她也很喜欢打猎。她大约12岁时就开了第一枪。阿什莉还在当地一家便利店打工，她希望在16岁生日时能攒够钱买辆车。
Ashley's mother Kathy Freeman was described as a loving and caring person She was a hard worker and was the main breadwinner for the family her father Danny Freeman He was known to have a little bit of a violent temper Ashley also had an older brother Shane He was three years older than her and after moving to Welsh there were a few issues starting to happen in the Freedman household There were reports of friction between Ashley and her father Not only that there was friction between her father and a brother In 1998 Shane ran away from home
阿什莉的母亲凯茜·弗里曼被描述为一个充满爱心和关怀的人。她工作努力，是家里的顶梁柱。至于她的父亲丹尼·弗里曼，据信他脾气有点暴躁。阿什莉还有一个哥哥叫谢恩，比她大三岁。搬到威尔士后，弗里曼家里开始出现一些问题。有报道称阿什莉和父亲之间存在摩擦。不仅如此，她父亲和哥哥之间也有摩擦。1998年，谢恩离家出走。
Danny rang the local sheriff's office to report Shane missing and they located him shortly after But Shane had injuries He reported to the local deputy that he had run away because his father had whipped him for disobeying him and his injuries were Significant enough that there was bleeding coming through his underwear As a result Danny Freeman was charged with assaulting Shane and a court date was set for the next year in 1999 But about four months later on January 8th 1999 the Freeman household would be devastated Shane had started to develop a bit of a taste for theft and on January 8th 1999 he stole his native vehicle and a gun I
丹尼给当地警长办公室打电话报告谢恩失踪，不久后他们找到了他。但谢恩身上有伤。他向当地副警长报告说，他离家出走是因为父亲因他违抗命令而狠狠鞭打了。他的伤势非常严重，内裤都渗出了血。因此，丹尼·弗里曼被指控袭击谢恩，并定于第二年（即1999年）出庭受审。但在大约四个月后的1999年1月8日，弗里曼一家遭遇了毁灭性的打击。谢恩开始对盗窃产生了一点兴趣，于1999年1月8日偷了一辆本国车辆和一把枪。
Little while later deputy David Hayes from Craig County Sheriff's Department spotted the vehicle on the side of the road He made his approach He pulled up and got out but almost immediately Shane confronted him and pulled a gun Deputy Hayes drew his gun and Screamed at Shane to drop it Shane refused forcing deputy Hayes to fire Shane died almost instantly An investigation by the County District Attorney found that deputy Hayes was acting in self-defense and the shooting was justified
不久后，克雷格县警长办公室的副警长大卫·海斯在路边发现了这辆车。他靠近过去，把车停下并下车，但谢恩几乎立刻就与他对抗并拔出枪来。海斯副警长拔出枪，大喊让谢恩放下武器。谢恩拒绝了，迫使海斯副警长开枪。谢恩当场身亡。县地方检察官的调查发现，海斯副警长是出于正当防卫，开枪是正当的。
This was devastating for the Freeman family and actually really struggled to come to terms with the death of a brother Laura played a big party in helping her friend through that tough time The Freeman family refused to believe the shooting was in self-defense They had grave doubts about the deputy's version of events They were of the belief that was a cold-blooded murder I can't find any information as to what made the Freemans think this if there was something in particular that led them to believe it But it's not unusual in cases of police shootings. It's a natural and understandable reaction from the family to blame the police Not their dead loved one
这对弗里曼一家来说是毁灭性的打击，阿什莉对哥哥的死实在难以接受。劳拉在帮助朋友度过这段艰难时期方面发挥了重要作用。弗里曼一家拒绝相信开枪是正当防卫。他们对副警长对事件经过的说法抱有严重怀疑。他们坚信这是一场冷血谋杀。我找不到任何关于是什么让弗里曼一家产生这种想法的信息，是否有某种特定因素导致他们这样认为。但在警察枪击案中，这并不罕见。这是家属将责任归咎于警方的一种自然且可以理解的反应，而不是指向他们死去的亲人。
The Freeman family started the post silence around town saying justice for Shane They really started to make noise about it and as a result a little bit of a feud started between the local sheriff's office and the Freeman family About a month after the shooting Danny Freeman was arrested after driving around attempting to find out where deputy David Hayes lived In response to that the local deputy started to sit outside the Freeman house in their patrol cars The tension was starting to run lower Later that year Danny still had to face court on the charge of assaulting Shane, but he was acquitted Laura played a huge part in helping Ashley come to terms with her brother's loss throughout that year And towards the end of the year on the 29th of December it was time to celebrate Ashley's 16th birthday
弗里曼一家开始在镇上发起沉默抗议，高喊“为谢恩讨回公道”。他们真的开始为此大声疾呼，结果导致当地警长办公室与弗里曼一家之间爆发了一点宿怨。枪击事件发生大约一个月后，丹尼·弗里曼因开车到处试图寻找副警长大卫·海斯住哪而被捕。作为回应，当地副警长开始开着巡逻车坐在弗里曼家门外。紧张局势开始升温。同年晚些时候，丹尼仍需因涉嫌袭击谢恩而面临法庭审判，但他被宣告无罪。在那一年里，劳拉在帮助阿什莉接受哥哥离世的事实方面发挥了巨大作用。到了年底的12月29日，是庆祝阿什莉16岁生日的时候了。
Ashley was still grieving she didn't feel like doing much. She didn't want to party Instead deciding to spend the day with the mother Kathy and of course Laura They went in the town. They went shopping They ate they spent the day together The girls decided that they wanted to have a sleepover And so after finishing up in town they stopped in at Laura's home And she got permission from her parents to sleep over at Ashley's house for a birthday It was about 7 p.m.
阿什莉仍在悲痛中，她提不起兴致做任何事。她不想开派对，而是决定和母亲凯茜以及当然还有劳拉一起度过这一天。她们去了镇上。她们逛了街，吃了东西，一起度过了这一天。女孩们决定办一个睡衣派对。因此，在镇上忙完后，她们顺道去了劳拉家，她得到了父母的批准，可以去阿什莉家过生日夜。当时大约是晚上7点。
Laura was driving she was 16. She had her own car and she drove herself to Ashley's She also took a purse with her and about two hundred dollars in cash And so Laura made her way to Ashley's place and they continued the birthday celebrations all still very low-key They ate cake and they watched a hunting show on TV a Little while later Ashley's boyfriend Jeremy Hurst turned up and gave Ashley her birthday present He stayed for a little while before leaving at about 9 30 p.m. He said everything was normal. It was a quiet night Just Laura and Ashley and Ashley's parents sitting around talking and watching TV
劳拉在开车，她16岁了。她有自己的车，自己开车去了阿什莉家。她还带了一个钱包和大约两百美元现金。于是劳拉动身前往阿什莉的住处，她们继续庆祝生日，一切依然非常低调。她们吃了蛋糕，在电视上看了狩猎节目。不久后，阿什莉的男友杰里米·赫斯特出现，送给阿什莉生日礼物。他呆了一会儿，在晚上9点30分左右离开。他说一切都很正常。这是一个安静的夜晚，只有劳拉、阿什莉以及阿什莉的父母坐在一起聊天看电视。
Nothing crazy going on at all Everything appeared normal until about 6 a.m. the next morning Thursday the 30th of December 1999 About 6 a.m. That next morning a neighbour of the Freemans called in to report the Freeman trailer was on fire It was still dark before sunrise There was a remote isolated area so the neighbour wasn't close But a trailer on fire obviously is hard to miss even from a long way away Welles volunteer firefighters rushed to the scene when they got there the Freeman trailer was still well alight, but they managed to put it out The Craig County Sheriff's Office arrived soon after and a crime scene was established
一切都很正常，直到第二天早上6点左右，也就是1999年12月30日星期四。第二天早上6点左右，弗里曼家的一位邻居打电话报告说弗里曼家的拖车着火了。当时天还没亮，太阳还没出来。这是一个偏远孤立的地区，所以邻居离得并不近。但一辆着火的拖车，即使从很远的地方看也显然很难忽视。威尔士志愿消防员赶到现场，到达时弗里曼家的拖车依然火势正旺，但他们设法将其扑灭。克雷格县警长办公室不久后赶到，并设立了犯罪现场。
The area was taped off It was about 7 30 a.m. When the rent Bible got a phone call that would turn her and her family's life upside down Her son called her at work to tell her the Freeman trailer had been destroyed by fire Pretty much as soon as she hung up local deputy arrived to tell her the bad news in person and that one body had been located But he didn't have too much more information The rent immediately called her husband and they rushed to the scene When they got there still in a state of shock and panic They saw it was taped off and there were a lot of deputies standing around but no one seemed to be doing too much
该地区被拉起了警戒线。大约早上7点30分，伦·拜布尔接到了一个将她和她家人的生活彻底颠覆的电话。她的儿子在上班时打电话告诉她，弗里曼家的拖车已被大火烧毁。几乎在她挂断电话的同时，当地副警长亲自赶来告诉她这个坏消息，并说已经找到了一具尸体。但他没有太多其他信息。伦立即给丈夫打电话，他们匆忙赶往现场。到达现场时，他们仍然处于震惊和恐慌状态，看到现场拉着警戒线，有很多副警长站在周围，但似乎没有人做太多事情。
No one was searching through the debris The Bibles were panicked and immediately questioned deputies about what they were doing to find their daughter They were told the investigation would not be starting until an agent arrived from the Oklahoma State Bureau of Investigation Otherwise known as the OSBI You see the deputies were well aware of what the Freeman family thought of them after Shane's death and they deemed it to be a conflict of interest for them to investigate They refused to handle the matter and instead called in the OSBI The OSBI is the state law enforcement agency for Oklahoma independent of the local county departments
没有人搜寻废墟。拜布尔夫妇感到恐慌，立即质问副警长们在做些什么来寻找他们的女儿。他们被告知，调查要等到俄克拉荷马州调查局（也称为OSBI）的探员到达后才会开始。你看，副警长们很清楚弗里曼一家在谢恩死后对他们的看法，他们认为由他们调查存在利益冲突。他们拒绝处理此事，而是请求OSBI介入。OSBI是俄克拉荷马州的州执法机构，独立于当地县部门。
This decision by Craig County Sheriff's Department may not have been the greatest as we'll see later The agent from the OSBI who would come to be in charge of the matter was agent Steve Nutter He arrived at the scene and the investigation commenced The body they had located was identified to be Kathy Freeman And by about 5 30 p.m. That afternoon they had decided that they had concluded their investigation of the scene They'd collected all the evidence they possibly could and Kathy's body was removed They told the Bibles that they were a hundred percent sure that there were no other bodies in the house As far as the Bibles could see though no search was conducted of the 40 acre property the Freemans lived on
正如我们稍后将看到的，克雷格县警长办公室的这个决定可能并不是最好的。负责此事的OSBI探员是史蒂夫·纳特探员。他抵达现场，调查随即展开。他们找到的尸体被确认是凯茜·弗里曼。到那天下午5点30分左右，他们决定结束对现场的调查。他们收集了所有可能收集到的证据，凯茜的尸体也被运走。他们告诉拜布尔夫妇，他们百分之百确定屋里没有其他尸体。然而据拜布尔夫妇所见，并没有对弗里曼一家居住的40英亩土地进行搜查。
The police were only worried about the trailer and the immediate surrounding area So Laura's father organized to fill the local ranges and they searched some of the property and horseback themselves But there was no trace of Danny or the girls So this raised some serious alarm bells Four people went to sleep in the trailer that night Three were unaccounted for Where were Danny Laura and Ashley? The Bibles were taken back to the police station where they were interviewed by OSBI agents
警察只关心拖车和紧邻的周围地区。因此，劳拉的父亲组织填补了当地的牧场，他们自己骑马搜寻了一部分土地。但没有丹尼或女孩们的踪迹。这敲响了严重的警钟。那天晚上有四个人在拖车里睡觉。三个人下落不明。丹尼、劳拉和阿什莉在哪里？拜布尔夫妇被带回警察局，接受了OSBI探员的盘问。
They were interviewed till around midnight Obviously a million things were been running through their minds But the number one thing was that Danny may have killed his wife and abducted the girls That was the only thing making sense at the time Otherwise what else could it be? There was a problem with that theory though both Danny and Kathy's cars were still parked in the driveway as was Laura's car It even still had the keys in the ignition Remember this is a remote area and they didn't own any other cars. So how did Danny get away with the girls?
他们被盘问到午夜左右。显然，无数的想法在他们脑海中闪过。但最主要的一种可能是丹尼杀死了他的妻子并绑架了女孩们。当时只有这种可能性才说得通。否则还能是什么呢？但这个理论有个问题：丹尼和凯茜的车都还停在车道上，劳拉的车也是。钥匙甚至还插在点火开关上。记住，这是一个偏远的地区，他们没有其他车。那么丹尼是怎么带着女孩们逃跑的呢？
The Rembibble also informed the OSBI agents that she was aware Danny had a history with drug use and maybe a little bit of drug viewing This immediately raised the possibility of another scenario a drug deal gone bad It did make sense and it would explain what Danny, Kathy and Laura's cars were still there if someone else had gone there and maybe taken them somewhere The Danny theory ended the drug theory. These were the two that were making the most sense at the time Much more sense than the other possibilities a random attack That seemed pretty unlikely It was a remote location. What are the chances of someone just stumbling across the Freeman's trailer? What about the possibility of the girls being responsible for this?
伦·比布尔还向OSBI探员透露，她知道丹尼有吸毒史，可能也参与了一点毒品交易。这立即引发了另一种设想的可能性：一桩谈崩了的毒品交易。这确实说得通，如果有人去了那里并把他们带到了某处，就能解释为什么丹尼、凯茜和劳拉的车还在那里。丹尼理论和毒品理论。这是当时最合理的两个假设。比其他可能性合理得多，比如随意的袭击。那似乎不太可能。那是一个偏远的地方。有人偶然撞见弗里曼家拖车的几率有多大？女孩们自己对此负责的可能性又如何呢？
Well, that was unimaginable not Laura and Ashley. There's no way they could have done it Earlier that next morning the 31st of December agent Nutter received some shopping news Kathy didn't die from the fire. She died from a shotgun blast to the head The time of death was estimated to be at 5 a.m. on the 30th It was also confirmed the fire was deliberately lit and accelerant had been used Not long after receiving that info the police got their first tip off Someone had called in to say that they saw Danny Freeman in a white Ford truck with both Laura and Ashley inside The caller said they saw them about 7 a.m
嗯，那是不可想象的，绝不是劳拉和阿什莉。她们绝对不可能做出这种事。第二天清早，即12月31日，纳特探员收到了一些令人震惊的消息。凯茜不是死于火灾。她是头部中了一枪身亡的。死亡时间估计在30日凌晨5点。还证实火灾是人为故意点燃的，使用了助燃剂。收到这一消息后不久，警方得到了第一个线索。有人打电话说，看到丹尼·弗里曼坐在一辆白色的福特卡车里，劳拉和阿什莉都在车内。打电话的人说他们看到她们是在早上7点左右。
So now the police the Bibles and relatives of the Freeman family thought they had their answer Danny murdered Kathy set the house on fire and a duck of the girls Seemed a likely scenario But that's not what happened Also earlier that morning on the 31st of December the Bibles returned to the Freeman property There was no longer a crime scene or the police and investigators had gone
所以现在警察、拜布尔夫妇和弗里曼一家的亲属都以为他们找到了答案：丹尼谋杀了凯茜，放火烧了房子并绑架了女孩们。这似乎是一个合理的剧本。但事实并非如此。也是在12月31日清早，拜布尔夫妇回到了弗里曼的住所。这里不再是犯罪现场，警察和调查人员已经离开了。
Just imagine what horrible thoughts and feelings they were going through They went back to the scene just to look around and Just in the hope maybe the police missed something Surely there's got to be a sign of the girls and what happened. They needed answers They needed to know where their daughter was Well, they found an answer all right They found a very big answer Not long after arriving at the Freeman property and sifting through the debris
试想一下他们当时正经历着多么可怕的想法和感受。他们回到现场只是为了四处看看，哪怕只是抱着警察可能漏掉了什么东西的希望。肯定会有关于女孩们以及发生了什么事的蛛丝马迹。他们需要答案。他们需要知道他们的女儿在哪里。好吧，他们确实找到了答案。他们找到了一个非常重大的答案。刚到达弗里曼住所并在废墟中筛查后不久
They found the burnt body of Danny Freeman steering back at them This was a major major problem There was already friction between the Freemans and the local sheriff's department And for that reason they called in the OSBI to take over of the matter and to avoid any conflicts of interest But somehow between them they managed to miss Danny Freeman's body Which took the Bibles all of about five minutes to find when they started sifting through the debris Somebody failed miserably The Bibles called Craig County Sheriff's office again and they arrived shortly after
他们发现了丹尼·弗里曼被烧焦的尸体正回望着他们。这是一个非常非常严重的问题。弗里曼家族和当地警长部门之间本来就存在摩擦。正因如此，他们才请来OSBI接手此事以避免任何利益冲突。但不知何故，他们在双方协作下竟然漏掉了丹尼·弗里曼的尸体，而拜布尔夫妇开始在废墟中搜寻时，仅仅花了大约五分钟就找到了。某个环节彻底失败了。拜布尔夫妇再次报警联系克雷格县警长办公室，他们不久后赶到。
Another crime scene was established and the OSBI was called back in The Bibles were told to leave the area because it was a crime scene, but they refused Lorraine raised a good point saying We let you do your job yesterday and look how well you did The Bibles weren't going anywhere Their daughter's body could very well be in amongst that debris It was determined soon after that Danny Freeman had also been killed with a shotgun blast to the head His charred body was found near where his wife's body was found in the bedroom
另一个犯罪现场被建立，OSBI再次被召回。拜布尔夫妇被告知离开该地区，因为这是一个犯罪现场，但他们拒绝了。洛兰提出了一个很好的观点，说道：“我们昨天让你们执行任务，看看你们干得有多好。”拜布尔夫妇哪儿也不去。他们女儿的尸体很可能就在这堆废墟中。不久后经确定，丹尼·弗里曼也是头部中了一枪身亡。他焦黑的尸体在卧室里被发现，紧挨着他妻子的尸体。
No shotgun was found nearby ruling out murder suicide Now imagine what the Bibles are thinking If the police missed Danny's body, they've probably missed Laura and Ashley's body as well An extensive search was carried out of the scene, but by the end of it the Bibles were told the police were a hundred percent sure There were no other bodies on site I'm not too sure how accompanying that was for the Bibles because that they had heard that story before The Bibles' grisly discovery had put an end to the theory that Danny had murdered his wife and abducted the girls
附近没有找到猎枪，从而排除了谋杀后自杀的可能。现在想象一下拜布尔夫妇的想法。如果警方漏掉了丹尼的尸体，他们可能也漏掉了劳拉和阿什莉的尸体。现场进行了广泛的搜查，但在搜查结束时，拜布尔夫妇被告知警方百分之百确信现场没有其他尸体。我不确定这对拜布尔夫妇来说有多大安慰，因为这种说法他们之前已经听过了。拜布尔夫妇可怕的发现打破了“丹尼谋杀了妻子并绑架了女孩们”的理论。
And obviously the tip-off the police had received earlier that morning was a false lead But it now raised the question Could Laura and Ashley have done this? It seemed impossible to loving caring girls good at school. No history of violence But police had to consider it Of course, there was the same problem as the Danny theory. How did they get away? What did they do murder Danny and Kathy set the trailer on fire and then run into the woods? All the cars were still in the driveway. Laura's purse was found at the scene still had the money in it and her ID
显然，警察那天早上早些时候收到的线索是一条错误的线索。但这现在提出了一个问题：劳拉和阿什莉会做这件事吗？这似乎不可能，两个充满爱心、关心他人、学习成绩好的女孩。没有暴力史。但警方不得不考虑这一点。当然，这和丹尼的理论面临同样的问题：她们是怎么逃跑的？她们做了什么？谋杀了丹尼和凯茜，点燃了拖车，然后逃进了树林？所有的车都还停在车道上。劳拉的钱包在现场被找到，里面还有钱和她的身份证。
Nothing was adding up. The only thing that made sense if Laura and Ashley were responsible Was that it was self-defense? What if Danny and Kathy had gotten into an argument Danny had shot Kathy then Ashley defending her mother shot Danny Ashley was an avid hunter and she had her own guns. It still seemed crazy, but it had to be considered As the investigation continued police learned that Danny had a large gun collection himself rifles and shotguns They were around 14 found at the scene But they wouldn't save the murder weapon was among them Police also learned that Ashley had close to $4,000 in cash saved up hidden in the freezer
一切都对不上。如果劳拉和阿什莉需要承担责任，唯一说得通的解释就是正当防卫？如果丹尼和凯茜发生了争吵，丹尼枪杀凯茜，然后阿什莉为了保护母亲而枪杀丹尼呢？阿什莉是个狂热的猎人，她有自己的枪。这听起来依然很疯狂，但必须纳入考量。随着调查的深入，警方了解到丹尼本人收藏了大量枪支，包括步枪和猎枪。在现场找到了大约14把。但他们无法确认谋杀凶器是否在其中。警方还了解到，阿什莉在冰箱里藏了将近4000美元现金。
That was the money she was going to use to buy her car But that money was gone There was no sign of it Someone who knew it was there had taken it The Freeman family Ashley's uncle and grandmother had their own theory which was pretty bizarre They were convinced the local sheriff's department was responsible finally putting an end to the bit of feud they had been having with the family since Shane's death Danny's brother even said that just prior to his death
那是她打算用来买车的钱。但那钱不见了。毫无踪迹。知道钱在那儿的人把它拿走了。弗里曼家族，即阿什莉的叔叔和祖母，有他们自己的理论，这相当离奇。他们坚信当地警长办公室是罪魁祸首，这最终了结了自从谢恩死后他们与该部门之间一直存在的小摩擦。丹尼的兄弟甚至说，就在他死前
Danny had an animated discussion with him and said if anything ever happens to me look at the sheriff's department Danny's brother said Danny was deadly serious when he said this pointing finger in his face Obviously Danny could easily have just been letting off steam by saying this being a bit worked up in a heated discussion Tensions were high with the sheriff's department and it could be a natural thing to say It then came out that the Freeman family were actually trying to save enough money to file a wrongful death suit in relation to Shane's death They only had one week left to come up with the money to file the suit Otherwise a year would have passed since Shane's death and they would no longer be able to file Danny's brother said the local deputies were trying to threaten and intimidate Danny Freeman not to go ahead with the case
丹尼曾与他进行过激烈的讨论，并说如果自己发生什么意外，去查查警长办公室。丹尼的兄弟说丹尼说这话时语气极其严肃，手指着他的脸。显然，丹尼当时可能只是在激烈的争论中情绪激动，借此发泄一下。当时与警长部门的关系本就高度紧张，说出这样的话也是人之常情。随后有消息传出，弗里曼一家其实一直在努力攒钱，准备就谢恩的死提起不当致死诉讼。他们只剩下一周时间来凑齐诉讼费。否则距离谢恩去世就满一年了，他们将再也无法起诉。丹尼的兄弟说，当地副警长一直在试图威胁和恐吓丹尼·弗里曼，让他不要把这个案子继续查下去。
The Freemans wouldn't drop this theory and were convinced the local deputies had killed Danny and Kathy and buried the girl somewhere The OSBI responded and put the local deputies on a lie detector test all passed with flying colors Agent Steve Nutter had this to say All cleared themselves as a result of those examinations The overall conclusion of our efforts was that the sheriff's office had nothing to do with the murders of Danny and Kathy And did not know the whereabouts of the two missing girls That's a pretty far reach to think that local deputies could have murdered Danny and Kathy and then abducted the two girls over a wrongful death suit
弗里曼一家不肯放弃这个理论，坚信当地副警长杀害了丹尼和凯茜，并将女孩们埋在某个地方。OSBI对此作出回应，让当地副警长接受了测谎仪测试，所有人都以优异的成绩通过了。史蒂夫·纳特探员对此发表了如下看法：“经过这些检测，所有人都洗清了嫌疑。我们调查工作的总体结论是，警长办公室与丹尼和凯茜的谋杀案无关，也不知道两名失踪女孩的下落。”认为当地副警长会因为一场不当致死诉讼而谋杀丹尼和凯茜，然后绑架两个女孩，这实在有些匪夷所思。
Wrongful death suits are nothing new to police departments and the death had already been real justifiable at the time by the district attorney It seems a bit of a stretch Clearly there was friction there and naturally the remaining members of the freeman family are going to look to put some blame on the local deputies The information received that the freemans were trying to come up with enough money to file a wrongful death claim was interesting It was found out that that amount of money they needed was $5,000 a pretty significant sum to come up with in one week It's already been mentioned that Danny was known to be involved in drugs. They may be a little bit of dealing Could he have gone in over his head looking for a big quick payday? Only to have the big deal go horribly wrong
不当致死诉讼对警察部门来说并不新鲜，而且当时该死亡已被地方检察官认定为正当。这似乎有点牵强。显然，那里确实存在摩擦，弗里曼家族的幸存成员自然会把一些责任归咎于当地副警长。收到的信息显示，弗里曼一家正试图筹集足够的资金来提起不当致死索赔，这很有趣。据发现，他们需要的金额是5,000美元，在一周内筹集到这笔钱是一个相当可观的数目。前面已经提到，众所周知丹尼涉嫌毒品。他们可能稍微做点毒品买卖。他会不会是为了追求一笔快速的大额金钱回报而铤而走险？结果这桩大买卖出了大问题？
It was certainly possible Or was it the OSBI didn't seem to think so Agent nutter thought that nothing fit correctly if it was drug related and that the very last thing anyone would want to do is Abduct the two girls if it was a drug matter Now here's privy to information that we aren't but that's an incredible comment If it was a drug deal gone horribly wrong Do you not think that the person or people responsible for shooting two people in the head and then burning their house down Wouldn't be capable of abducting two girls
这当然是有可能的。或者OSBI并不这么认为？纳特探员认为，如果是毒品相关的案件，没有什么是完全合乎逻辑的，而且如果是毒品事件，任何人最不想做的事就是绑架这两个女孩。现在，他掌握着我们所不知道的信息，但这真是一个惊人的评论。如果是一桩出了大问题的毒品交易。你难道不认为那个枪击两人头部然后放火烧毁他们房子的凶手或凶手们，有能力绑架两个女孩吗？
Of course they would be and for any number of reasons I don't think you need too much of an imagination to know why people Capable of such horrific violence would want to take two 16-year-old girls with them By now an autopsy had been performed on Danny and it was revealed he had a fracture on his right collar bone Indicating there could have been a fierce struggle before he was killed On New Year's Day the local community banded together and over 500 people performed a large search of the Freeman property But the search turned out nothing It's like Laura and Ashley disappeared off the face of the earth
他们当然有能力，原因可能有很多。我想你不需要太多想象力就能知道，为什么有能力做出如此恐怖暴力行为的人，会想要带走两个16岁的女孩。此时，尸检已经在丹尼身上进行，结果显示他的右锁骨骨折，这表明他在被杀之前可能进行过激烈的挣扎。元旦那天，当地社区团结起来，超过500人对弗里曼的财产进行了大规模搜查。但搜查一无所获。就好像劳拉和阿什莉人间蒸发了一样。
On friday the 7th of january 2000 a memorial service was held for Danny and Kathy Over 400 people were in attendance The investigation continued but the police had nothing no witnesses no leads no real suspects It was 18 months later when they got their first solid break or so they thought A couple of inmates at the local county jail reported that they saw Ashley and Laura at a farmhouse in Ottawa County on New Year's Eve 1999 the day after their disappearance And it wasn't any house it was a house well known to police It belonged to the Glover family who were known meth manufacturers
2000年1月7日星期五，人们为丹尼和凯茜举行了一场追悼会。超过400人出席。调查仍在继续，但警方一无所获：没有目击者，没有线索，没有真正的嫌疑人。18个月后，他们迎来了第一个重大突破，或者他们是这么认为的。当地县监狱的一对囚犯报告说，在1999年12月31日，也就是他们失踪的第二天，他们在渥太华县的一处农舍里看到了阿什莉和劳拉。而且这不是普通的房子，这是一栋警方熟知的房子。它属于格洛弗家族，他们是众所周知的冰毒制造商。
These inmates reported seeing Ashley and Laura being drugged raped and tortured at the house and apparently someone had filmed it One of the inmates had saw the tape Police immediately applied for a search warrant and on the 26th of july 2001 they raided the Glover house But the only thing they found was evidence of drug manufacture They did find a spot of blood in the house and the sample was taken back to the lab But the lab was busy the Bible family were told they would have the results back in a year One whole year As if the Bible's on the rest of the Freeman family hadn't suffered enough
这些囚犯报告说，看到阿什莉和劳拉在房子里被喂毒品、强奸和虐待，显然有人将其拍了下来。其中一名囚犯看过录像带。警方立即申请了搜查令，并于2001年7月26日突击搜查了格洛弗的房子。但他们唯一找到的是制造毒品的证据。他们在房子里发现了一处血迹，并将样本带回了实验室。但实验室很忙，拜布尔家族被告知一年后才能拿到结果。整整一年！仿佛拜布尔家族和弗里曼家族的其他成员遭受的折磨还不够多。
Now they had to wonder for a whole year if this story by the inmates at the local county was true And if that blood belonged to either Ashley or Laura Well, they suffered through the year and were told that it wasn't a match It wasn't actually all Laura's blood No trace of the girls were found in the Glover house police were back to square one Like a lot of cases that garner significant media attention There were all types of crazy tip-offs and people calling in with sightings of the girls all over the country These calls only got worse when a $50,000 reward was offered in exchange for information leading to an arrest
现在他们得整整一年都在琢磨，当地县监狱那些囚犯的话是不是真的，那血迹究竟属于阿什莉还是劳拉。好吧，他们熬过了这一年，却被告知那并不是匹配的血样。其实根本不是劳拉的血。在格洛弗的房子里没有找到女孩们的任何踪迹，警方又回到了原点。就像许多引起重大媒体关注的案件一样，有各种各样的疯狂线索，人们从全国各地打电话说看到了这些女孩。当悬赏5万美元以换取能促成逮捕的信息时，这些电话变得更加糟糕。
Police were even receiving calls putting the girls in totally opposite parts of the country on the same day As the investigation went on police decided to look into other cases that had been committed around the time of the Freeman case Both in Oklahoma itself and in neighboring states to see if any similar crimes were committed with a similar remote And they found one case that stuck out It was the case of Tommy Lynn cells Tommy Lynn cells was on death row for the horrific murder of 13 year old Kaleen Harris In the evening of the 30th of December 1999 Tommy was drinking at a bar and he eventually got kicked out for inappropriate behavior towards a barmaid After being kicked out he decided to force his way into a nearby trailer
警方甚至接到电话，说女孩们在同一天出现在该国完全相反的两个地方。随着调查的深入，警方决定调查在弗里曼案发生前后发生的其他案件，无论是在俄克拉荷马州本身还是在邻近各州，看看是否发生了类似的、手法相似的犯罪。他们发现了一个格外突出的案件。这就是托米·林·塞尔斯的案件。托米·林·塞尔斯因为残忍谋杀13岁的卡琳·哈里斯而被判处死刑。1999年12月30日晚上，托米在一家酒吧喝酒，最终因对女酒保行为不端而被赶了出去。被赶出去后，他决定强行闯入附近的一辆拖车。
He murdered Kaleen and then cut the throat of a friend Her friend acted dead and Tommy left Kaleen's friend then rushed to a neighbor's house police were called and Tommy Lynn cells was arrested soon after Incredible bravery from Kaleen's friend only 10 years old This happened in the early hours of the 31st of December 1999 Only the day after the Freeman attack And it happened in Texas, which is the neighboring state to Oklahoma So Tommy would have had enough time to go from the Freeman case to Texas and commit this murder
他谋杀了卡琳，然后割断了一个朋友的喉咙。她的朋友假装死了，托米便离开了。卡琳的朋友随即冲到邻居家，警察被叫来，托米·林·塞尔斯很快被捕。卡琳的朋友表现出令人难以置信的勇敢，她当时只有10岁。这发生在1999年12月31日的清晨。就在弗里曼遇袭案的第二天。而且它发生在得克萨斯州，即俄克拉荷马州的邻州。所以托米有足够的时间从弗里曼案发地赶到得克萨斯州并犯下这起谋杀案。
There were differences in the two crimes, but both were horrific in their nature And police wanted to look into Tommy Lynn cells a little bit more Agent Nutter and the new Craig County Sheriff Jimmy Souter made their way to death row to interview him At first he gave them nothing But after about six hours of interrogation he started to confess to the crime He claimed to have buried Laura and Ashley at Red River on the border of Oklahoma and Texas Police took cells to the site and he pointed out where he thought he had buried him, but there was a problem Not only were no remains found, but the site was completely different to what cells had described earlier
这两起犯罪存在差异，但其本质都极其残忍。警方希望对托米·林·塞尔斯作进一步调查。纳特探员和新任克雷格县警长吉米·苏特前往死囚牢房去讯问他。起初他什么也没说。但在大约六个小时的审讯后，他开始承认罪行。他声称将劳拉和阿什莉埋在俄克拉荷马州和得克萨斯州交界处的红河。警察把塞尔斯带到现场，他指出了他认为自己埋藏尸体的地方，但出了问题。不仅没有找到任何遗骸，而且该地点与塞尔斯先前描述的完全不同。
Also cells had a complete lack of knowledge of any of the more intimate details of the case He only knew what was in the paper And cells had a habit of confessing to murders While he was on death row he confessed to over 70 Police do think he was responsible for around 20 of the murders But they also think he was playing the system confessing to a whole heap of crimes. He didn't commit Maybe he just wanted to gain more notoriety Maybe he liked the attention. Maybe he was trying to get special privileges
此外，塞尔斯对案子的任何更深层细节都极度缺乏了解。他只知道报纸上登的内容。而且塞尔斯有承认谋杀的习惯。在死囚牢房服刑期间，他承认了70多起谋杀。警方确实认为他对大约20起谋杀负有责任。但他们也认为他在玩弄司法系统，承认了一大堆他根本没有犯下的罪行。也许他只是想获得更多的恶名？也许他喜欢这种关注？也许他试图获得特权？
And he did get out of his cell for a day after confessing to the Freeman crime to go to the alleged burial site So as crazy as confessing to a murder he didn't commit sounds There were a number of reasons why Tommy would make a false confession And he had nothing to lose. He was already on death row But whatever the reason was it became pretty clear to police that cells most likely had nothing to do with the Freeman case And he wasn't charged He was executed by the state of texas on april 3rd 2014 Oh
他在承认弗里曼罪行后确实被带出牢房一天，去指认所谓的埋尸地点。因此，尽管承认自己没有犯下的谋杀听起来很疯狂，但托米会做出虚假自供的原因有很多。而且他已经没有什么可失去的了。他已经在死囚牢房里了。但不管出于什么原因，警方逐渐变得很清楚：塞尔斯很可能与弗里曼案毫无关系。他没有被起诉。他于2014年4月3日被得克萨斯州执行死刑。哦
Tommy glean cells wasn't the only inmate on death row to confess to the murders of the freemans and laura bible Jeremy B. Jones was on death row for a sickening murder and police became very interested in him when he confessed In december 2000 Jeremy B. Jones was wanted on two separate rake charges in oklahoma He fled the state and went to alabama He managed to steal somebody's identity and his new identity was john paul chatman Not long after he got himself into trouble again, and he was arrested of fingerprint The prince was sent to the fbi and incredibly their system failed to match his prince to his real identity Jeremy B. Jones
托米·格林·塞尔斯并不是死囚牢房里唯一一个承认谋杀弗里曼一家和劳拉·拜布尔的囚犯。杰里米·B·琼斯因一起令人作呕的谋杀案被判死刑，在他供认后，警方对他的兴趣大增。2000年12月，杰里米·B·琼斯因俄克拉荷马州的两起独立强奸指控而被通缉。他逃离该州前往阿拉巴马州。他设法偷走了别人的身份，新身份是约翰·保尔·查特曼。不久后他又惹上麻烦，因指纹被捕。指纹被发送给联邦调查局，令人难以置信的是，他们的系统未能将他的指纹与他的真实身份杰里米·B·琼斯匹配起来。
So a new profile was created for him under his new identity john paul chatman And he was never arrested or died at back to oklahoma to face the rape charges On september 18th 2004 45-year-old lisa nichols was found dead She had been raped and shot in the head inside her trailer, which was then set on fire Very similar to what happened in the freemen case Jones was arrested after his vehicle was seen out the front of lisa's trailer the night of the murder Police caught up with him and this time they eventually worked out his real identity as being Jeremy B. Jones, not john chatman Jones admitted to killing nichols, but that's not all he confessed to
因此，在他的新身份约翰·保尔·查特曼名下为他创建了一个新档案。他从未被捕或被引渡回俄克拉荷马州面对强奸指控。2004年9月18日，45岁的莉莎·尼科尔斯被发现死亡。她在一辆拖车内遭到强奸并头部中枪，随后拖车被纵火焚烧。这与弗里曼案中发生的情况惊人相似。谋杀当晚，莉莎的拖车前停着琼斯的车，随后他被捕。警方追上了他，这次他们最终查明了他的真实身份是杰里米·B·琼斯，而不是约翰·查特曼。琼斯承认杀害了尼科尔斯，但这还不是全部，他还供认了其他罪行。
He confessed to 13 other murders across six states Although police could only find enough evidence to charge him with three of those murders Jones was convicted and sentenced to death And while he was on death row in july 2005, Jones confessed to four more murders Those of danny kathy and ashley freeman and laura bible It didn't take long for the police to really like to look of jeremy b. Jones Not only was the murder of lisa nichols very similar in nature to the freemen case But on the night the freemen's were murdered
他供认了横跨六个州的另外13起谋杀案。尽管警方只能找到足够的证据指控他犯下其中三起谋杀，但琼斯仍被定罪并被判处死刑。2005年7月，在死囚牢房服刑期间，琼斯又承认了另外四起谋杀。也就是丹尼、凯茜、阿什莉·弗里曼以及劳拉·拜布尔。警方没花多久就对杰里米·B·琼斯产生了浓厚兴趣。莉莎·尼科尔斯案的作案性质不仅与弗里曼案高度相似，而且就在弗里曼一家被谋杀的当晚
Jeremy B. Jones was arrested for public intoxication only 16 kilometers away from the freemen property Or 10 miles if you prefer so that put him in the area And he was arrested for the murder of lisa nichols Agent nutter and sheriff suitor immediately went to the state of alabama to interview jones Strangely at first he denied any knowledge of the crime even though he had just confessed to it But as the interrogation went on he started to admit his involvement He said that danny owed him drug money So he shot him he then shot kathy and set the house on fire
杰里米·B·琼斯因在距离弗里曼家仅16公里（或者你更喜欢的话，10英里）的地方公开醉酒而被捕。这使他出现在案发地区。而他后来又因谋杀莉莎·尼科尔斯而被捕。纳特探员和苏特警长立即前往阿拉巴马州盘问琼斯。奇怪的是，起初他否认对这起犯罪有任何了解，尽管他刚刚才供认过。但随着审讯的深入，他开始承认自己参与其中。他说丹尼欠他毒资。所以他开枪打死了他，接着枪杀了凯茜并放火烧了房子。
He didn't even know the two girls were there until they ran out of the house screaming He tied the girls up put them in his truck and then he killed them and dumped them in a kansas mine shaft Unlike the confession of tommy lindsell's Jeremy B. Jones knew some things about the case that really got the attention of suitor and nutter He knew the exact accelerant that was used to start the fire and he knew the type of shotgun that was used to commit the murders This information had never been released to the public Police immediately set up a search of the kansas mine shaft where jones said he dumped the bodies, but there were problems There were over a hundred mines in the area and there was a system of underground water tunnels
他甚至不知道那两个女孩也在屋里，直到她们尖叫着从屋里跑出来。他把女孩们绑起来，放进卡车里，然后把她们杀害并抛弃在堪萨斯的一个矿井里。与托米·林·塞尔斯的自白不同，杰里米·B·琼斯知道一些关于此案的细节，这确实引起了苏特和纳特的注意。他知道引发火灾的确切助燃剂，也知道用来行凶的猎枪型号。这些信息从未向公众公布。警方立即着手搜查堪萨斯矿井，也就是琼斯说他抛尸的地方，但遇到了问题。该地区有一百多座矿井，还有一个地下水通道系统。
So anything you dumped in would float away Regardless the area was searched extensively over several days including the use of underwater camera equipment But no trace of the girls was found When jones found out the police had come up empty he immediately took back his confession setting made it all up He's setting made it up to get special privileges. He got extra phone calls extra visitation and special meals Police also had another look at his arrest for public intoxication Now first I thought it was great news as I put him in the area
因此，你扔进去的任何东西都会漂走。无论如何，警方对该地区进行了多日的广泛搜查，包括使用了水下摄像设备。但没有找到女孩们的丝毫踪迹。当琼斯发现警方一无所获时，他立即翻供，宣称这一切都是他编造的。他宣称这一切都是为了获得特权。他获得了额外的通话时间、额外的探视权和特餐。警方还重新审视了他因公开醉酒而被捕的事。起初他们认为这是个好消息，因为这把他带到了案发地区。
But they saw he was arrested at 4 a.m. On the 30th of december The time of death on catty freeman was estimated at 5 a.m. And the drive from the freeman property To the mine where he said he dumped the bodies and back It was about an hour The latest he could have left was 3 a.m Two hours before the estimated time of death And it's thought the fire was started after catty was killed as well. So the times weren't really adding up
但他们看到他是在12月30日凌晨4点被捕的。凯茜·弗里曼的死亡时间估计在凌晨5点。从弗里曼住所到他说他抛尸的矿井并返回的车程大约需要一个小时。他最晚离开的时间必须是凌晨3点。比估计的死亡时间早了两小时。人们认为火灾也是在凯茜遇害后才被点燃的。所以时间上其实对不上。
But this didn't mean jeremy b jones wasn't responsible in some way anyway The crimes could easily have been committed by more than one person And for whatever reason jeremy b jones may have been left to wander away from the freeman residents While whoever else that was responsible Drove off with the girls Jeremy may have been mixing in what he did now about the case and making up the rest In order to confess to the crime to get those extra privileges But then for whatever reason decided to take back their confession
但这并不意味着杰里米·B·琼斯在某种程度上就没有责任。这些罪行很可能是由不止一个人犯下的。不管出于什么原因，杰里米·B·琼斯可能被留下来，独自从弗里曼住宅附近离开，而其他负有责任的人则开车带着女孩们离开。杰里米可能将他现在对案件的了解与自己编造的内容混杂在一起，以便通过认罪来获得额外的特权，但随后不知出于什么原因，又决定推翻他们的口供。
Jeremy b jones remains a suspect, but he's never been charged with the crime He's still on death row for the other murders Cells and jones are as close as the police have ever gotten to arresting anyone for the murders and for their disappearance of ashley and laura For some reason 11 years after the murders in 2010 the osb I thought it would be a good idea to release details of a suspicious vehicle seen in the area of the freeman property around the time of the murders The vehicle was described as a dark four-door sedan and it was seen between 5 30 a.m. And 6 a.m The osb I said they did not release details of this vehicle at the time because it was a vague description And they decided to keep that information within law enforcement ranks
杰里米·B·琼斯仍然是一个嫌疑人，但他从未被指控犯下此罪。他目前因另几起谋杀案仍被关押在死囚牢房中。塞尔斯和琼斯是警方有史以来最接近逮捕谋杀案凶手以及阿什利和劳拉失踪案嫌疑人的人。出于某种原因，在谋杀案发生11年后的2010年，俄克拉荷马州调查局（OSBI）认为公布在谋杀案发生前后在弗里曼宅邸附近发现的一辆可疑车辆的细节是个好主意。该车被描述为一辆深色四门轿车，是在凌晨5点30分到6点之间被看到的。OSBI表示，当时没有公布这辆车的细节，是因为描述比较模糊，他们决定将该信息保留在执法部门内部。
A ridiculous decision that information should have been released to the public at the time Somebody might have seen it or somebody might have been able to shed some light on People that own similar cars who could have been persons of interest It's extremely optimistic to think that any information is going to come to light 11 years later At the same time they also released details of a second vehicle seen around the area of the freeman property around the same time between 5 30 a.m. And 6 This vehicle was described as a dark colored heavy-duty pickup truck and it was seen heading north towards kansas The osb I said this information was received in a recent interview, which at the time was 2010
这是一个荒谬的决定，这些信息当时本应向公众公开。当时可能会有人看到它，或者有人能够为拥有类似汽车、可能成为涉案人员的人提供一些线索。要想在11年后让任何信息浮出水面，这种想法未免过于乐观了。与此同时，他们还公布了在同一时间段（即5点30分到6点之间）在弗里曼宅邸附近看到的第二辆车的细节。这辆车被描述为一辆深色重型皮卡车，当时正向北朝堪萨斯州方向驶去。OSBI表示，这些信息是在近期（即当时的2010年）的一次采访中获得的。
So how reliable that information was in that interview 11 years later is anyone's guess And obviously the osb I didn't get any useful information because the case is still unsolved And continues to be investigated to this day Leads have been followed up all around the country, but there is still no trace of law nationally So what happened to the girls it's like they dropped off the face of the earth It seems unlikely two 16-year-old well behaved girls would be able to commit such a horrible crime and then vanish without a trace Taking none of their belongings with them This seems to leave only one scenario they two were victims
因此，11年后那次采访中的信息究竟有多可靠，谁也说不准。很显然，OSBI并没有得到任何有用的信息，因为该案至今仍未侦破，并且仍在调查中。全国各地的线索都被跟进了，但劳拉依然下落不明。那么女孩们到底怎么了？感觉她们就像是从人间蒸发了一样。两个16岁、乖巧听话的女孩似乎不太可能犯下如此可怕的罪行，然后又消失得无影无踪，并且没有带走任何随身物品。这似乎只留下了另一种可能：她们俩是受害者。
But why weren't they shot dead and left in the house with Danny and Kathy? Why were they taken? Where were they taken? Who took the $4,000 that actually had hidden and how did they know it was there? There are still no solid suspects in the case other than maybe Jeremy B. Jones, but he hasn't been charged yet 11 years after his confession It's highly unlikely police are ever going to charge him. They obviously don't think he was responsible There is surprisingly little mention of Ashley's boyfriend in all the material of source in this case He was there that night. He was the last one to see anyone alive All I've been able to find out about him since is that he suffers depression and survivors guilt Somebody out there knows something
但为什么她们没有被枪杀并和丹尼以及凯西一起留在屋里？为什么她们被带走了？她们被带到了哪里？谁拿走了丹尼藏起来的4000美元，又是怎么知道它在那里的？除了可能是杰里米·B·琼斯之外，本案中仍然没有确凿的嫌疑人，但在他认罪11年后，他仍未被起诉。警方几乎不可能再起诉他了。很显然，他们认为他并非罪魁祸首。在本案的所有资料中，令人惊讶的是，对阿什利男友的提及少之又少。他那天晚上也在场。他是最后一个看到任何人活着的人。我所能了解到的关于他后来的情况是，他患有抑郁症和幸存者负罪感。总有人知道些什么。
Hopefully in time that somebody comes forward or there is a piece of information that helps break the case wide open Ashley's family have since had her ruled legally dead. That is a step that the bible's refused to take with laura Every night the rem bible leaves the porch light on Just in case laura comes home All right I can see you're not all right After all the absent nights If I had the chance to make the problems go away, I swear I would
希望假以时日，知情人能站出来，或者能有线索帮助案件取得重大突破。阿什利家人此后已将她法律宣告死亡。那是劳拉的家属拒绝在劳拉身上采取的一步。每天晚上，劳拉的家属都会亮着门廊灯，以防劳拉回家。好吧，我看得出你状态不好。经历了所有缺席的夜晚后，如果我有机会让问题消失，我发誓我会的。
Kill them today I swear I would Kill them today There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
今天就杀了他们，我发誓我会的。今天就杀了他们。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。